[Music]
with flips and jumps part of the sport
active skateboarders damaged their decks
beyond repair every few months but
instead of tossing the ruined
skateboards into landfills they're being
reclaimed for a different kind of trick
a transformation into electric guitars
from skateboards to fret boards it may
seem quite a leap but making electric
guitars out of old skateboards is not
such a wild idea skateboards are often
made of multiple layers of rock maple
which is a traditional tone wood for
guitars a guitar maker evaluates the
condition and color of the boards and
once he's made his selections he aims a
heat gun at the grip tape on top to
soften it he prized the edges of the
softened tape away from the board using
a razor he grabs the tape and pulls it
off the skateboard he can now get a
better look at the damage done to the
board and he decides it can be salvaged
he sands off the adhesive and the
graphics the sanding doesn't remove the
turquoise color the dye has penetrated
the wood it is part of its intrinsic
appeal he cuts off the nose and the tail
of the board and discards them he'll
just be using the wheel basis the next
step is to laminate five the skateboards
together he applies a liberal coat of
glue spreading it with a putty knife for
complete coverage he adds the final
board to the glued stack and places the
stack in a hydraulic clamp to protect
the surface of the skateboards he sets a
wooden board on top the clamp squeezes
the skateboard sandwich together as the
glue sets a day later he removes the now
laminated skate boards a blade shaves
the surface of the stack smooth and
brings out the grain he trims the edges
of the stack so that they're more even
he applies glue in a zig-zag pattern to
one of the side edges and spreads it
across the entire edge he joins another
skateboard stack to this one and clamps
the two together
fuse together they form a block that's
large enough to be crafted into an
electric guitar body with a pencil he
traces around the template of a guitar
shape to transfer the outline to the
laminated skate boards using a bandsaw
he cuts out the shape the skateboard
colors form a random pattern within the
guitar shape
he places the template on the guitar
body once again
and secures it with double-sided tape
with a router he refines the profile
giving the guitar smoother lines using a
different pattern as a guide here outs
and drills cavities to accommodate the
guitars neck electronics and bridge he
removes the template and inspects his
work
he sands the edges of the cavity smooth
then he drilled several holes in the
back of the guitar for attaching the
neck later with the guitar body held
steady in a clamp he bores a hole for
the input jack
[Music]
after crafting the neck of the guitar
from reclaimed skateboards he files it
aggressively to shape it to the desired
profile
he then sands the entire neck the body
undergoes an extensive sanding - and
then he coats it with clear gloss this
is the first of seven to eight coats
with the sanding in between each one
with curing time this lacquering process
takes three weeks after a wet sanding
and buffing the guitar body and neck
have a mirror finish the guitar maker
Nestle's the neck in the hollow space at
the front of the body and screws it in
place from the back of the guitar this
recycled skateboard get our can now be
assembled and wired and is set up to
rock
it takes a month to transform some
battered old skateboards into a sleek
electric guitar trading the halfpipe for
the stage these skateboards are no
longer has bins
[Music]